[موسيقى]
بسبب التهميش المنهج حسب ما يقولون والذي
تعرض اليه الكاكايون لا توجد هناك
احصائيات محدده حول اعدادهم والسبب عدم
اعتراف الكثير من الحكومات في العراق وفي
ايران بتلك الديانه
التقينا مع عضو البرلمان اقليم كردستان
سيروان بابا باباني الذي حدثنا عن تقصير
الحكومه تجاه هذه الطائفه الدينيه
يعود الى ثلاثه الاف عام او اكثر الان اخر
احصائيه لعدد الككائيين وهي احصائيه خاطئه
بالتاكيد تقول تلك الاحصائيه ان عدد
الكتاكيئين يبلغ 120,000 نسمه مع العلم
انه لا يوجد تعداد سكاني منذ فتره طويله
ولكن هل نمتلك احصائيه عن عددهم قبل 100
عام مثلا كلاوه هذا يدل على اهمالنا وعدم
اهتمامنا بالموضوع
التالي اكبر عدد من الكاكائيين يوجدون في
محافظه كركوك وثانيا في محافظه نينوى
ثالثا في محافظه ديالى ورابعا في اداره
ومن ثم في محافظتي حلبجه وبعد ذلك في
محافظه اربيل
غابات وكذلك في محافظه السليمانيه ويقدر
عدد السكان
في جميع هذه المناطق بنحو
20000 نسمه في جميع انحاء العراق
اليماني
قضيه تخص ملكيه الارض بين عربي وكاكاي
والتقيت به بالقرب من قضاء داقوق فاظهر لي
مجموعه من الاوراق والوثائق وبعد قراءتها
اتضح انه صاحب الارض ولكن لكونه كاكائيا
حكم القاضي لصالح الطرف الاخر في بعض
الاحيان قبل الذهاب الى المحكمه تعقد
جلسات صلح وربما يتوصلون من خلالها الى حل
المشكله ولكن ان لم يتوصلوا الى نتيجه يتم
حل المشكله بالعنف احيانا